Speaker 1: We have new video from another one
of these school board meetings. This one took
place yesterday. Why is it always Florida?
This one was in Seminole County, Florida.
I have two clips here to play for you
in this first clip. A guy who shows up
says that vaccines are a deep state
conspiracy to depopulate the world.
And this is. The most listen to this, the most
fascinating element of this is this guy says
you can't even learn this stuff from Fox
News anymore. He is too radical for Fox
News. Fox News isn't giving him what he wants
anymore. He's telling you the truth. You won't
get it on Fox News because Fox News and Hannity
have been compromised. Let's listen together.
Speaker 2: Squirter, allow the speaker to finish.
Thank you. State medical establishment wants
all of us to be depopulate. I know
you guys think that's a conspiracy
theory, but it's not a conspiracy fact.
And they're all in cahoots with each other
to depopulate us. They want us divided. They want
all of us to fight each other so they can win.
Speaker 1: This is now what would be the like?
Of course, this doesn't pass the sniff test,
but what would be the point of a mass
population? Right. I mean, the centers of power,
if ultimately money is their motivation, you get
money from people who buy goods and services. At
the end of the day, that's what it is. And that
could be buy health care services or that could be
byproducts or consume streaming or whatever
it is. What on earth would cause the centers
of power to want to depopulate anyway? Like it
doesn't even pass the sniff test versus evil?
Speaker 2: Evil is not going to prevail. All
you've done is awaken the sleeping giant,
hear every parent here.
Speaker 1: The language is,
of course, of delusions of grandeur and
incredible self aggrandizement freedom,
Speaker 2: except maybe some of them that
are brainwashed by the deep state media.
I used to watch Fox News deliberately. I'm a
conservative. I won't even watch that now because.
Speaker 1: Did you did he need to tell
us he's a conservative? But listen
to what he says about Fox, Hannity,
Speaker 2: all the rest of them are.
Let me tell you who I do listen to, which
are renowned doctors, Dr. Sherri Tenpenny,
Speaker 3: Dr. Chris
Speaker 1: Tenpenny,
is that complete and total lunatic who
was talking about the vaccine magnetizing,
you and and some other things. What do we do about
this? Do the I'm all for public comment periods.
School boards are unable to get anything
done because of these comment periods and
these outrageous conspiracy theories that
are showing up who tell us Fox News is, too.
Fox News won't tell you the truth. They've been
compromised. But Tenpenny will tell you the truth.
And there's a massive population plan. What are
we do we need to end the public comment periods?
One more clip from this same meeting. Here's a
woman who went to the same Seminole County school
board meeting and she talks about she hits all
the shit she's doing ivermectin. She's bringing
back Bill Gates. It's unbelievable. It is so
Speaker 4: sad. Maskers are touting death
rates in hospitals as excuses to
mass kids having moved into what's
really causing these deaths. Hospital protocols,
Speaker 1: the crowd cheering that what people are
dying from isn't covid. It's hospital protocol.
Speaker 4:
Cryderman infusions of hospitals, ivermectin,
HQ. Why? Because it's not accepted by the
National Institute of Health. Why drugs? These
drugs have been around for years and have been
used worldwide. Why won't they use them?
Speaker 1: Here's the key. Now, remember,
those things have been peer reviewed. There have
been other cities and they show no statistically
significant effect on covid. The fact that a drug
has been approved for something else doesn't tell
us whether it's effective for covid. This is it's
part of the disinformation that they rely on,
Unidentified: on the money.
Speaker 1:
In fact, it's actually the
opposite. They say there's money,
there's more money to be you wouldn't make money
using ivermectin or hydroxy chloroquine. Actually,
the reason, as we talked about this
with Vincent Racaniello yesterday,
the reason these drugs start to be tested is
because they are so cheap and they're just
sitting around and doctors say, I've got nothing
else for it. Let me try it. It's the reverse
causality of what these people are talking
Speaker 4: about is what we need to do, OK?
And it's it's cheap and cheap. Why doesn't
it work? Wink, wink. Follow me now.
No. Agencies like the CDC and the FDA do not work
for the American taxpayers. They are nonprofit
organizations that work for companies, politicians
and individuals like Bill Gates for years, iPIX.
For years, I think complaints have been lodged
against these agencies for the cozy relationships
between them and the companies they are
Speaker 1: supposed to raise. So it's always some
kind of conspiracy. So what do we do? Is it time
to end the public comment periods? Is it time to
what? What? I don't know what to do. My instinct
is never to suppress speech. I'm all about public
comment periods at city councils, school boards,
et cetera. But this is a nationwide epidemic
of these school board meetings just being taken
over by these people. I don't know how it should
be handled. Let me know what you think.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Welcome back to the show. Remember, we are a
program funded mostly by viewers and listeners
who sign up at Join Pakman dot com. I invite you
to do so today. And through the rest of the week,
you can use the coupon code billions
to save billions now to save bigly,
thanks to the one billion YouTube view
milestone that we reached earlier this
week. The coupon code billions saving
you money every day at Join Pakman Dotcom